all right hi this is my friend Luca he's
actually my language tutor this is not
really plan we don't know what we're
talking about here to introduce yourself
Luca of course I'm Luca as you said on
time language instructor a language
trainer yeah yep and so if I speak
horrible French it's all his fault he's
yeah yeah no Luca would you say it's
kind of okay you're you have to you have
one good thing about you you have one
bad thing about you oh the one bad thing
about you is obviously you're Italian
obviously you choose apparently yes I am
but it is the good thing though is is
you are somewhat humble okay put this
you can correct me however you want
there's like a world out there of
polyglots people who could speak
multiple languages and you're kind of
not a celebrity what would you call
yourself here you're a very well-known
polyglot throughout your bridges very
well yeah well I don't really know how
popular
it looks like a popular bite at the
messages they get you actually know this
life so speaking of 12 languages doesn't
make me a better person than anybody
else it's just a matter of you know
being able to be looking more powerful
having more chances in life because when
you speak 12 languages you can do a lot
of stuff you know the monolingual people
come out dude even if there's a few
people think that for example speaking
languages everybody speaks English
that's why they claim sometimes and so
is you just speak English that's okay
but if you speak other languages you got
a lot of chances life it's not just a
matter of talking people it's a matter
of you know job opportunities girls for
the most romantic some of you and in
general it changes your life to change
mine but at the same time as I said
before speaking 12 languages as a result
of the way you live so it's not
necessarily sometimes when people told
me you tell me your material would you
mean well what is the definition here
I'll say it and say oh you've
accomplished something but it's more my
way of living that does make a
difference you know
in this regard being humble just the way
I serve myself a simple person simple
tastes and that's the way I am so
speaking languages for having thousands
of people watching my videos on YouTube
doesn't change of the facts it doesn't
change my life
no actually did change my life but it
didn't change me as a person right it
changed who you are I mean it changed
their life as better your life but
you're still the same all Luca that you
were before and hopefully I'm gonna stay
that way for the rest of my life
not very good one question that like
I've always wondered for guys like
ourselves that like not just learning
languages but I think skill sets like I
don't care if it's guitar language
calculus whatever why do we do this to
ourselves like you know I mean this pain
because most people they try to learn
guitar they try to learn Spanish
whatever and after you're feeling stupid
12 out of 12 times they stop why do we
keep trucking on well I think that this
whole thing comes down to motivation or
results in life a lot of people just
thought he's going to see the point of
it some people just you know do it for
this you have to have something in mind
you have to have a clearer way word for
example what am I going to do the
Spanish am i learning Spanish for a
specific reason
and then if you find that music and for
example if you start learning Spanish
and you find a specific reason living it
in the foreign country beating it girl
reading books in that language this you
try to struggle everybody's strong
everybody struggles you know it's not
just because I'm smarter than the others
I struggle small for example the
Japanese have been struggling for 2
years more or less or on the language
but the idea of you know when every time
I watch a Japanese movie or every time
you know they talk about Japan
you know this dis Sparkle this this this
thing in me it sponson monster in me he
wants to learn because I know that
learning Japanese to change my life same
thing with the guitar you play the
guitar music and tell yourself well it's
just a holiday you know play the cards
we just want to learn to play a little
bit that's sometimes sometimes in your
life a moment comes when
the work went to use you know you're
going to play the guitar for you know a
friend advice who says hey you know
that's that guy could make it the last
minute you want to join us and it could
change your life so playing the guitar
it's not it could be not only to perform
in public but you know what I think
for example playing the guitar playing
this turn into something that I've been
to you know if I used to play the piano
when I was a little kid I dropped it too
soon and you know it's you know why the
biggest regrets of my life because what
I'm Seth one of the best things that can
happen to you
I don't know that never happen here tell
me better play the guitar me too
yes but life you know you playing the
guitar you like absorb and you're you're
creating something so it's not just or
even you know languages playing the
guitar being able to do something else
that completes you it right so whenever
you struggle you have to remember that
you know everybody doing something well
you know everybody you know it's a
urinal
how can you can they do it it's a lot of
training it's a lot of it stronger but
the satisfaction didn't get out of it
it's like so big that it's worth every
single move every student strongly ya
know so it's no that's a good point
because I think we're all dreamers we
all see all men I can see myself playing
that guitar you know to that girl or I
can't wait to speak this language to
this different many people but some
people they just they hit that barrier
and they just stop beeping maybe I guess
we just keep reminding ourselves and I
think that every learning process in
every learning process the psychological
factor is so important and you have to
take care you have to take into account
that kind of factor and language
learning that's so important in guitar
and playing the guitar etc etc so when
you do you know you ever heard of
hitting a little plateau oh yeah so you
tend to think oh I'm not gonna you know
I just hit the Litella
I don't know what to do to go to the
next phase but you have to remember that
every single thing
you do if you if you if you stick to it
every day you will improve you the fact
that you don't see improvements in fact
ah you used you think thing you're not a
professor
it's not true actually you are improving
everything what you should do it's like
stick abide by this this very simple
principle which is actually one of the
most different things will remain
learners as well as for you know I wants
to play at the Target Center is that a
lot of people cannot don't do it every
day a little bit wouldn't was they'll I
don't have time you know I have to do
this I know you got other fish to fry
it's not true you know there's a very
famous guy back 2,000 years ago and you
have to remember that when the Romans
said something it's most probably true
yeah you see it's not the waiter
halftime it's just that we make poor use
of it if you think about it you always
find time to do something like every day
yeah one more time to gain in the throws
or you can do something else the wheel
is my time to do something you like and
if we start enjoy something that a lot
of people can see they're struggling
let's suppose that a lot of a lot of
Americans right now they're learning
Spanish they go to school they tell you
okay you have to learn Spanish because
it's yeah badge because you need a
schooling or a sewer but if they change
this kind of framework and it's all you
know
you imagine what you can do with Spanish
it could change your life in so many in
so many ways people would be motivated
and would start enjoying it every time
the every time it studied something they
learn how to go and wear something else
and every little piece is gonna add to
you know glory as they call it
it's Gore now glorious tool in some way
now I'm talking about myself as a
polyglot a person speaks a lot of males
I can tell you it's glory sometimes you
were wrapped up by glory I talking all
these language not because it's not
because people are it's not I don't I
don't seek people's admiration actually
I seek a better life it's different and
I have to say the last five years a lot
of things happen and a lot of beautiful
things are still happening to me because
of the way I embrace I embrace the a
lifetime probably the lifestyle you know
it allows me to travel to get to know
people it's so easy it is glorious you
know from explored and Goris it's much
better because glory lore is something
that you have at the bottom Iruvar
anything keep it forever while
admiration of people
and wings with time you know yeah but
glorious state with you pull the end of
your face there's so much more to it
than just you know A's and B's and
dotting eyes and it's a right to hold
it's a whole mindset then I think yeah
you said it very well so all right so
from the streets of Paris I guess you
can say goodbye in Portuguese goodbye in
Portuguese Spanish and what's a couple
of French at the same time ciao
okay so you get T for example ciao ciao
is Italian is a handle that's that's
kind of sweet family again
we're bye-bye which is Chinese Maithili
completes its Japanese officials in
Russia which is a German customary law
which is in Spanish teams are split
which is in Catalan what else
husky American is a piece out pizza
so peace out and it's prepares lots of
awesome